speaker series hosted by the Yale Center
for business in the environment my name
is linh tran and i will be your host for
this afternoon's presentation titled
water and energy synergies the Yale
Center for business and the environment
is pleased to present blueprint for
efficiency this series of public
webinars emphasizes the latest
opportunities for energy efficiency
through presentations that look at
corporate nonprofit and public private
developments blueprint explores energy
efficiency through the lenses of
behavior policy finance and technology
each presentation is recorded and
available on the blueprint proficiency
website and the Yale University iTunes
channel be sure to join us next thursday
March 26 for harnessing energy embedded
in water with Amelia nuding from Western
resource advocates and Gretchen hard
instance for the Los Angeles Department
of Water and Power in today's webinar we
will explore synergies and water and
energy management practices with our
speaker dr. Katrina gostosa Katrina is
an assistant professor in the Department
of Agricultural and resources economics
at UC Davis and an affiliate of the UC
Davis center for water energy efficiency
where she specializes in environmental
and energy economics much of her
research centers are in consumer and
firm behavior in the energy and water
sectors in her research she often
collaborates with electric and water
utilities as well as state agencies
finally we would like to remind our
listeners that we welcome any questions
you might have and we will direct them
to our speaker at the conclusion of the
talk please type questions directly into
the go to webinar chat window throughout
the presentation and with that we'd like
to welcome Katrina to blueprint for
efficiency
hi everyone um I hope everyone can hear
me so my name is Katrina gesso thanks so
much for having me today to give this
webinar I'm going to talk a little bit
today about water and energy synergies
and I should mention that what I'm
talking about today is reflective of
joint work with gay blade Frank load as
well as Ned Spain so before I kind of
dive into the presentation I want to
give you a quick overview for what I'm
going to talk about today so first I'm
going to give you a bird's eye view of
what we mean when we talk about the
water energy Nexus then I'm going to
briefly talk about what the Center for
water energy efficiency at UC Davis is
doing and then I'm going to deep dive
into one project that's keeping me up at
night so let's get going so let's start
with a bird eyes bird's eye view of this
topic water is a significant consumer of
energy in California accounting for over
twenty percent of energy use in
California the three most
energy-intensive activities are the
movement of water the treatment of water
and the heating of water this latter
category right end use heating of water
which you can think about is you know
heating your shower or washing your
clothes accounts for about sixty to
seventy percent of water-related energy
use so as you can see from the slide
water consumes electricity so think
about pumping water over the mountains
to transport it from northern to
southern california it uses natural gas
so think about this is heating the water
in your household and it uses quite a
bit of diesel and you can think about
this in California as agricultural pumps
extracting groundwater so motivated by
these observations what we're really
interested in doing is identifying
opportunities to save both water and
energy and in general to gain a better
understanding of the relationship
between energy usage and water usage
this issue has only become
more important given the severity of the
current drought in California
policymakers are implementing water
conservation measures and if water
conservation induces energy conservation
this further adds to the value of water
conservation efforts just the last thing
I want to note is that if you look at
the flush right part of the screen what
you'll see is energy consumption in
Northern vs southern california and
you'll see that they're different well
why is that because a large amount of
water is moved from Northern California
to Southern California and this requires
energy to transport and kind of treat
the water so why is energy so why excuse
me why is water so energy intensive well
here we have an energy that's added to
the water lifecycle and we see this in
each colored box and what you could see
is that energy is consumed in the
transport so that's the supply and
conveyance treatment and end use of
water consumption it's also involved in
the recycling of water as well as the
treatment of wastewater so what I want
you to gain from the slide is just the
fact that water is a large consumer of
energy now as a utility one can imagine
that you're interested in saving energy
and water related activities so there's
two routes you could take to achieve
this goal of energy savings so what we
have here is kind of illustrations with
the water glasses and lightning bolts of
the two different paths you can take so
let's look at the kind of the top
illustration well in this illustration
you can make the water infrastructure
components more energy-efficient so you
can improve the palms or the treatment
processes and what this would do is this
would yield a reduction in energy
consumed with the same amount of water
delivered alternatively you could go
about gaining energy conservation or
energy savings by reducing water
consumption so under this scenario which
is depicted in the bottom half of the
screen less energy
required to deliver a smaller amount of
water to end-users and this latter
component that is kind of gaining both
water and energy conservation is what
the Center for water and energy
efficiency focus is on the Center for
water and energy efficiency at UC Davis
is working on understanding the water G
energy Nexus and achieving the joint
goal of water and energy conservation
and water conservation along with load
management it's led by Frank Loesch so
he's the director and Ned Spang and it's
part of the UC Davis energy you hub
which was established in 2011 so if you
ever come to UC Davis what you'll see is
there's this whole part of campus called
West Village that's dedicated to energy
efficiency issues the mission of the
center for water and energy efficiency
is to research develop and disseminate
efficient technologies and effective
policy for integrated water and energy
conservation so how is the center
attempting to achieve this mission well
what it's done sorry I should have
flipped the slide is it's partnered with
a number of water electric and natural
gas utilities as well as government
agencies foundations and private
companies this partnership kind of
allows us to kind of test or analyze
investigate the water energy Nexus in
collaboration in conjunction with those
who care the most about it or the most
interested in it this also makes kind of
the research that we're doing here at
the center much more policy relevant
so now that I've given you a bird's eye
view of the water energy Nexus and I've
talked a little bit about the center
what I want to spend the bulk of my time
doing today is giving you a flavor for
one project that we are working on what
this project seeks to do is it we want
to understand whether water conservation
programs aimed at end use water usage
can meaningfully and cost-effectively
impact natural gas usage so what we're
going to ask in this project is we're
going to ask what is the effect of water
conservation programs on water usage
energy usage defined here is natural gas
usage and what's the effect of these
different programs on the uptake of
energy and water efficient appliances
how are we going to go about doing this
well we have partnered with Burbank
Water and Power Southern California gas
and the software company water smart to
design and implement a frame field
experiment a concept to which I'll
return in a few minutes and again like I
said earlier in this experiment what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at the effect of water conservation
programs on water usage energy usage and
the uptake operation both water and
energy efficient appliances so why is
this study important well what's the
studies going to do is it's going to
offer insights to policymakers on the
water energy nexus and it's also going
to speak to the relative ability of
price and non-price interventions to
achieve water conservation so let's
think about the policy implications of
the first well estimates from this study
will provide some of the first data
points on the potential of water
conservation programs to achieve cost
effective energy savings and it will
inform water NAT and natural gas
utilities and the cpuc that's the Public
Utilities Commission on the cost
effectiveness of these programs the
second reason this is an important study
kind of from a policy perspective is do
kind of particularly right now to the
severity of the current drought so right
now policymakers are interested in kind
of seeking out or
testing or learning how to kind of best
reduce water usage or to best achieve
conservation given the current drought
and we'll be able to speak to that we'll
be able to kind of get at how can you
till ities most effectively reduce water
demand among urban residential water
users so now let's be a bit more formal
about this study that we're going to
talk about today so in this study we're
going to deploy three alternative home
water reports to consumers in Southern
California and what we're going to do is
this kind of deployment of these three
home water reports azilla is going to
allow us to test three questions or ask
three questions first it's going to
allow us to look at the effect of a
behavioral based hot water messaging on
both water usage and natural gas usage
second it's going to allow us to ask
whether hot water messaging social
comparisons and conservation
recommendations can lead to cost
effective natural gas conservation and
then third what we're also going to look
at is we're going to also look at the
incremental effect of an economic
incentive on water and natural gas usage
that is we're going to be able to
analyze what's the combined effect of
messaging hot water messaging as well as
a small economic incentive on both water
and natural gas usage so how are we
going to do this well before I dive into
the details of our study I want to talk
a little bit more broadly about research
design I think this is a really
important issue kind of and I want to
make sure that we're all on board with
it so as a thought experiment let's
imagine that a utility to has decided to
offer all of its customers of voluntary
conservation program so in this scenario
customers can select into a water
conservation program or not
and then we're going to look at the
impact of this water conservation
program on both water usage as well as
natural gas usage in actuality kind of
if you work for utility what you know is
that we see many volunteer voluntary
programs being offered what are examples
of these well you can imagine electronic
billing does a house would want to
engage or not engage electronic billing
if your electric utility does a
household select into or not time-of-use
pricing etc but again what we're focused
on here is a water conservation program
that's voluntarily offered to consumers
households have now chosen whether or
not to participate in this program so
our sample is now comprised of two
groups of households those who choose to
participate in the program and those who
do not choose to participate in the
program so now how would we go about
figuring out what's the effect of this
conservation program on water and
natural gas usage well in a naive
approach or naive comparison what we
would do is we would simply compare
water usage across those who select into
the program against those who choose not
to participate in this program this
comparison would provide us with an
estimate of the treatment effect in the
figure that you should all now have kind
of on your computer this is reflected as
the difference between usage and the
control group which is the blue line and
the treatment group which is the red
line after the start of the program this
difference is given by that red arrow or
the red line with the word estimated to
the words estimated treatment effect
extra so to get a better understanding
for this let's quickly describe the
figure this figure on the x-axis we have
time and on the y-axis we have water
usage the blue line plots water usage in
the control group and the red line plots
water usage in the treatment group
we compare usage across the two groups
prior to the start of the program where
the start of the program is indicated by
the vertical red line with the arrow
pointing to it which is labeled start
date of the program so if you look to
the left of the vertical line what
you'll see is you'll see the difference
or you'll see that there's differences
in water usage across the control group
and the treatment group in general the
control group consumes more water than
the treatment group so what we can glean
or what we can infer from this figure is
that those who choose to participate in
the program and those who do not choose
to participate in the program are
meaningfully different in their
consumption habits that is households
opting into the program the treatment
group may have less usage simply because
they're greener they're more interested
in finding ways to reduce their usage or
maybe they're different just because
they're more technologically savvy so
why is this why are we concerned about
this why am i spending so much time
talking about this well now let's look
at usage once the program starts so now
let's look to the right of that vertical
line well once the program starts what
we observe is we do observe a reduction
in water usage however a simple
comparison across control and treatment
group will give us a misleading estimate
of the treatment effect why is that well
this estimated treatment effect is
comprised of two pieces the first is the
effect of the program highlighted by the
black arrow and the second highlighted
by the yellow arrow reflects the fact
that the treatment and control groups
are different from each other right
they're systematically different from
each other that is control group might
be more technologically savvy or more
green what we want to do is what we want
to get is an estimate of that black line
we want to be able to isolate the black
line but this method right justice naive
comparison only provides us with an
estimate of the red line so why do we
care well when we're trying to
understand what's the impact of a
program on water usage and energy usage
and where we're trying to get
a sense or an estimate of the cost
effectiveness of a program it's
imperative or critical that we have a
solid or credible estimate of the actual
treatment effect of the program so to
address this concern we're going to
deploy what we call a randomized
controlled trial in a randomized control
trial what you do under this
experimental design is we're going to
randomly assign households to either a
control group that is they would not
receive the water conservation program
or a treatment group that is they will
receive the water conservation program
note that households will not choose
whether or not they receive the
conservation program instead it will be
determined randomly that is whether or
not they get the conservation program is
random right it's independent of their
characteristics what the random
assignment buys us is that there will be
no systematic differences between the
two groups so on average the two groups
should be equally as concerned about the
environment equally is interested in
saving on their electricity or water
bills and equally as interested in or
technologically astute so now I want to
provide you with a slide that shows or
illustrates the intuition behind a
randomized control trial so in contrast
to the previous figure if we now look or
compare usage across the control and
treatment group prior to the beginning
of the program what you'll see is that
there's no difference across the two
groups because these two groups control
and treatment are similar differences in
usage once the intervention starts can
be attributed to the intervention and in
this case it can be attributed to the
conservation program so why is this
method so valuable well what it allows
us to do is it allows us to isolate the
effect of the conservation program on
usage this is critical if we want to
kind of get at or understand the
linkages between water and energy usage
and
we want to figure out how to best induce
conservation among residential water and
energy consumers this method is also
important to utilities in California why
because it meets the highest level of
rigor and reliability as defined for the
CPU sees California valuation protocol
so the CPUC has certain standards that
it requires when it's looking at or
evaluating the conservation induced by
different energy efficiency programs and
randomized control trials are one method
that mean kind of this standard for
rigor and reliability so now what we
have or where we are is you should all
have an understanding of how we're going
to tackle this question so now let's get
into the nuts and bolts of our
experiment so in this study what we're
interested in looking at is urban water
and energy conservation in California so
to do this like I previously mentioned
we partnered first with Burbank water
and power this is a public or city-owned
utility serving approximately
twenty-three thousand five hundred
residential customers as well as
additional commercial customers we also
partnered with Southern California gas
which is an investor-owned natural gas
company serving a large portion of
consumers in Southern California the
timeline for this project is spring 2015
to spring 2016 so it will last for a
year and it's getting rolled out as we
speak so I just want to qualify a lot of
the stuff that I'm going to talk about
today is hypothetical it's in the works
but maybe some of the details um the
small details of the project will change
in this project our sample is going to
be comprised of 18,000 single-family
homes so you can think about household
as an observation or the cross sectional
unit of study and we will have 18,000
single-family homes what's really unique
and so if you're kind of dozing off or
you're distracted now's a good time to
listen so I can tell you kind of one
thing that's really unique about our
study and one reason why it will be
informative well in our study what we'll
be able to record or what we'll be able
to observe is one reason why we picked
both Southern California gas in the city
of Burbank is that we're going to have
hourly water and natural gas usage data
for all households so for every one of
these eighteen thousand households will
be able to observe their water use and
natural gas usage every single hour so
this will not only allow us to determine
if conservation is occurring but also
when conservation is occurring and maybe
how habits of consumption change in
response to these interventions so now
let me give you a quick overview about
these interventions that I've been
referring to so in this experiment what
we're going to do is we're going to
randomly assign households to either a
control group so 3025 households will be
randomly assigned to a control group
recall that these households for these
households use control households we
will collect hourly water usage and
natural gas usage data now I quickly
want to give you an overview of the lay
of the land for the treatments before we
delve into the specifics of each one so
fifteen thousand households are going to
be assigned to one of three treatment
groups where each treatment is going to
be comprised of roughly five thousand
households in the first treatment
households will receive kind of the
typical or conventional home water
reports that will be provided by or
deployed by water smart so this is the
typical type of water report a point to
which I'll return later that's deployed
by water smart in the second treatment
so that's treatment one typical water
smart treatment too is what we're going
to be called what we're calling hot
water smart so the second treatment will
receive home water reports that target
target hot water as opposed simply
overall water usage again we're going to
refer to this treatment as hot water
smart
there will also be a third treatment so
five thousand households will be
randomly assigned to a third treatment
what we call conserve and win these
households will receive the hot water
smart interventions they will receive
the hot water smart treatment plus they
will receive an economic incentive where
the purpose of this economic and center
is to further encourage or entice them
to reduce water and natural gas
consumption so again hassles will be
randomly assigned to a control group or
one of three treatment groups a generic
water smart treatment a hot water smart
treatment tailored at hot water and in
turn natural gas conservation and a
conservative wind treatment where these
households receive both hot water
messaging as well as a small economic
incentive okay so let's talk a bit about
this first treatment water smart so
households assigned to this treatment
will receive over course of a year six
home water reports so every other month
they will receive a home water report
these have these home water reports will
be sent either electronically for
households enrolled in electronic
building billing or via paper for
households enrolled in paper billing
there's also some exceptions to this
rule which I can talk about more folks
have questions what these home water
reports do is they compare your own
usage to that so let me kind of flip to
the next slide so you can get an
overview so what these home water
reports do is they focus on overall
household water usage and how to induce
conservation there's three ways that
they seek to achieve this they provide
recommendations information and social
comparisons so they're going to compare
your usage to that of your neighbors to
your past usage and provide kind of
actionable information on ways to use
water around the home more efficiently
these home water reports aim to motivate
households to reduce their water use
through changes in behavior
or through the adoption of more
efficient technologies so now let's zoom
in on the different features of this
home water report and how they attempt
to get customers to reduce their water
usage so again in this slide what we
have is we just have a picture of one
hypothetical home water report so it's
comprised of three pieces the first are
social comparisons so the most
well-known aspect of these home water
reports is a social comparisons aspect
in this part of the whole water report
your usage is compared to that of your
similar neighbors so as you can see from
this example the household receiving the
home water report consumes 174 gallons
per day they're doing better than their
average neighbor who concerns consumes
198 gallons per day but not as well as
they're efficient neighbor who consumes
135 gallons per day the intention of the
social comparison is perhaps it will
encourage the household in an effort to
be more like efficient neighbors to
conserve or reduce more water these
whole water reports are also comprised
of kind of on one portion of the home
water report provides individualized
recommendations that suggest how a
household could best save water so again
like this part of the figure or which
part of the home water report shows
there's water savings actions water
saving actions that are tailored
individually for each customer so
they're selected based on your household
characteristics yard side and historical
water use so here a household could
change their plants from grass to native
plants this would save 241 dollars per
day this water saving action it kind of
is comprised more of higher upfront
costs however households can also engage
in water saving actions that don't
require more upfront costs but do yield
real water savings so you can imagine
just filling up the clothes washer so
running fewer loads of laundry a week
this would save for this household about
nine gallons
per day or an average $55 Pierre per
year alternatively household could
install a faucet aerator that would lead
to 12 gallons of saving of water savings
per day which totals are amounts to 72
dollars per year so the second component
of this home water report are these
recommendations the third component of
these hot water reports is what we call
messaging so in this messaging
households um so in this messaging what
we kind of seed for this individual
household is it tells the households if
you took the actions below where the
actions are the recommendations I just
highlighted in the previous slide a
household could reduce their water use
by 83 gallons per day and save
themselves 368 dollars per year also
what this message says them is that this
would trigger a household to become
comparable in water usage to their
efficient neighbor so in this
information may further motivate
households to conserve so this suite of
treatments right these messages these
recommendations in these social
comparisons are intended to lead to
overall reductions in water usage the
impact of water smart i should mention
has been documented right and so there
is a nice study done these water smart
home water reports were deployed in the
East Bay which is a part of California
and they were then evaluated by a
consulting firm and the program under
this report was estimated to have
reduced water by about four point eight
percent so about a five percent
conservation of effect simply from the
deployment of these home water reports
so what's new about our study well a
second treatment like I talked about is
what we're going to what we dub hot
water smart so in the hot water smart
treatment what we're really interested
in understanding or gaining insights
into is whether or not hot water
messaging represents or describes a
plausible and cost-effective channel by
to reduce natural gas usage so in this
treatment whole water reports will focus
on both overall water conservation and
hot water conservation so to do this
half the messages and recommendations
will be tailored to hot water usage so
as you can see from the third bullet the
only difference between treatment one
the typical water smart home water
report and treatment to the hot water
smart home water report is that half the
recommendations and messages will be
tailored to hot water usage one thing I
want to mention before kind of moving on
to some examples of what this hot water
smart intervention will look like is I
just want to think about one implication
of our research design and what this is
is that if we compare treatment one that
is the overall water smart home water
reports to treatment to which our
recommendations and messages tailored to
hot water savings what we might find is
that we may find that treatment two
yields fewer less overall water
conservation than treatment one well why
is this well the water conservation
potential of hot water activities will
definitely differ from the conservation
potential of cold water activities say
for example taking a shorter shower
versus watering your lawn one fewer day
per week watering your lawn one for your
day per week will definitely unsaved
moreover while all water usage however
the natural gas consumption of these two
activities that is taking a shorter
shower versus watering your lawn one for
your day per week will also differ with
taking shorter showers sorry that's a
tongue twister yielding energy
conservation and irrigating your lawn
not altering and use natural gas
consumption all I'm trying to say here
is is kind of what policy we prefer
whether it be the hot water smart or the
typical water smart simply depends on
what our objectives are are they just
water conservation or are they
dual goal of natural gas and water
conservation so what will this hold
water home hot water report look like
well first it will be comprised of
recommendations so I should mention that
the social comparisons for the hot water
smart treatment will be identical to the
social comparisons for the water smart
treatment so we will just be comparing
households to similar neighbors along
the dimension of overall water usage
recommendations though will differ
between the two treatments so half about
what the recommendations in the hot
water smart recommendation will be
tailored to hot water usage so these
will be comprised of excuse me okay so
what will these hot water
recommendations look like well one can
see an example of the individualized
water saving record recommendations we
might offer again this is hypothetical
so in this recommendation we have a
mixture of outdoor water savings
recommendations as well as hot water or
simply here natural gas savings
recommendations so turning down the
water heater temp or decreasing the pool
temp will yield large natural gas
savings and large dollar savings look
six hundred and seven dollars per year
just by decreasing your pool temp by two
degrees but it will not yield any water
savings in contrast changing grass to
native plants will yield water savings
but no energy savings so these are two
extremes of recommendations the first
provides gas savings but no water
savings and the second generates the
reverse that is water savings with no
gas savings however if households kind
of engage in both these types of actions
combined they may induce water and
natural gas savings I should mention
that there are also actions that will
yield the dual gains of water and
natural gas savings so an example of
this would be a recommendation provided
in an earlier slide which encourages an
individual to kind of fill up their
clothes washer before running a
load of laundry if we use less hot water
this will yield both water and natural
gas stations excuse me if we run fewer
loads of laundry in which kind of we run
them on a warm or hot cycle this will
yield or use less water and less natural
gas in addition to recommendations
tailored to hot water usage will also
provide messages tailored to hot water
usage this will yield kind of both water
and energy conservation so here's an
example of one in this message which
again is hypothetical we are alerting
households to freely available energy
efficiency starter kits so these kits
will provide hassles with a low-flow
showerhead and three faucet aerators but
all of these technologies can yield
small energy and water savings well
what's the value of this message well in
this message we're alerting households
to efficiency programs about which they
may be currently unaware so we're making
these existing rebates or energy and
water efficiency programs more salient
again in this treatment in this hot
water smart treatment one of our main
goals is to try to achieve natural gas
reductions through the channel of hot
water conservation our third and final
treatment conserve and win is what we
call conserve and win and it's going to
be randomly allocated like i said
earlier to five thousand households
these households will receive the exact
same messages and recommendations as the
hot water smart treatment or the
messages and recommendations we've just
described however these households will
also receive a small economic incentive
that intends intends to further
encourage natural gas and energy
conservation so just to make it clear
the only difference between treatment to
and treatment 3 that is the hot water
smart intervention and the conserving
win treatment is that the conserve and
wind treatment also provides a small
economic incentive so what will this
incentive look like well all households
in this treatment
will be entered into a raffle and in
this raffle they will be guaranteed
guaranteed to win an efficient durable
good if that is if they achieve certain
conservation targets for example we can
imagine studying the conservation target
at five percent water conservation and
three percent natural gas conservation
so to be eligible for this raffle
household would need to reduce their
water in natural gas usage by three and
five percent as compared to the previous
year so the annual conservation we need
to be three and five percent when
compared to the previous year if
households meet these conservation goals
then they will be entered into a raffle
where they can win either a clothes
washer a high-end shower head or an
energy efficiency kit so there's two
distinct features of this raffle one is
that they're guaranteed to win something
and two is that there's a relatively
high probability of winning a really
valuable item so there's a pretty darn
high probability of winning for say per
se an energy-efficient and clothes
washer how are households going to be
informed about their progress towards
meeting this kind of goal this
conservation target well they're going
to be informed of their progress via
their home water reports so on two of
the six home water reports will provide
them with updates on their progress so
now let's take a look at what this
treatment actually looks like so
households enrolled in the conserve and
win program will receive the following
message on their first home water report
this message provides a brief
description about the program so it says
conserve and win reduce your water use
by ten percent and natural gas used by
five percent and be guaranteed to win an
energy-efficient home appliance for more
details go to blah blah blah and it
tells the household where can go to
learn all the details about this program
households will then be updated on their
progress via two reports they can also
learn about their progress via the web
so in this report for example a
household is informed that it's twelve
percent of the way
both in terms of water and natural gas
usage towards meeting the predetermined
conservation requirement so what's so
valuable about this treatment well what
it's going to do this conserve and wind
treatment is it's going to allow us to
test how much more households are
induced or incentivized to conserve when
they provided with a really small
economic center incentive it may be the
case that the most cost-effective way to
achieve natural gas and water savings is
through the joint impact of an economic
incentive and behavior based messaging
alternatively it may be the case that
this economic incentive has no
incremental impact on conservation that
is households are simply responding to
the behavior based messaging in this
study we're going to be able to compare
or test these competing hypotheses so
I've now given you an overview of both
our study and the methodology we will
deploy to answer our questions of
interest once the experiment is complete
which it clearly is not well you can now
ask sir ask ourselves well what can we
learn so the first thing we'll do is
we're going to compare water usage
natural gas usage and investment in
energy and water durables across the
control and treatment groups this will
provide us with one of the very first
estimates of the end use energy savings
from various water conservation
instruments and it will speak to the
cost effectiveness of each policy we
will then or we will also be able to
compare across policies and weigh in on
the impact of behavior based water
conservation instruments and their
ability to achieve water and energy
savings in of themselves and as compared
to say a hot water conservation
treatment we will also be able to
quantify the incremental effect of an
economic incentive on natural gas and
water conservation usage so at least in
my mind this study is valuable from a
policy perspective along two dimensions
first we will provide one of the first
credible
of evidence on the cost-effectiveness of
achieving energy efficiency defined here
as natural gas savings through water
conservation programs the cpuc is
currently deciding where to include
whether or not to include these these
water efficiency programs as energy
efficiency programs however and rightly
so before allocating energy efficiency
dollars to water efficiency programs
they want clear defensible methods for
calculating the energy intensity of
water and so reliable and verifiable
monitoring of energy savings need to be
established this studying kind of is one
of the first steps in this direction and
towards kind of achieving this goal a
second dimension along which this study
is quite policy relevant pertains to the
drought so given the severity of the
current drought in California
policymakers are looking into the
preferred instruments to manage urban
water or induce urban water conservation
we can weigh in on this in particular by
comparing the savings from a behavior
based treatment alone as compared to the
savings when we couple a small economic
incentive with behavior based messaging
lastly the study will improve our
understanding of customer decision
making in the residential natural gas
and water sectors something with just a
far come from complete this is important
because understanding how customers make
decisions will improve our ability to
design effective conservation policies
and manage both water and energy kind of
more effectively so thanks again for
taking the time to join the webinar
today the Center for water and energy
efficiency is always looking for new
partnerships and projects so please
please please feel free to reach out to
us and in particular Nets ping whose
information I provided the Associate
Director if you're interested in
learning more also if you have any
questions about the study or want to
offer up any feedback or alternatively
if you're interested in kind of
collaborating on a project or running a
randomized control trial I'd love to
hear from you and I provided my contact
information as well so feel
three to be in touch so thanks again and
I'm now looking forward to your
questions great thank you so much for
that great presentation Katrina we have
quite a few questions that are coming in
so I'm going to get started right away
to see if we can get in as many as
possible so the first question is from
en and the question is is SoCalGas also
sending home energy reports either by
itself or in conjunction with Southern
California Edison if so what is the plan
for separating at these potential
effects
great question in that's actually one I
had when we started on this project and
actually SoCalGas has sent out Home
Energy reports they haven't done it in
the jurisdiction of Burbank yet and
we're kind of we're currently talking
with them about kind of how to make this
work in a separate project though with
the Center for water and energy
efficiency what I've done is we're
partnering with PG&E as well as East Bay
mud and what we're going to look at is
we're going to look at the impact of
home water reports on water usage the
impacts of Home Energy reports on energy
usage as well as the joint impacts of
these two programs that is if a
household receives a Home Energy Report
as well as a home water report we're
going to look at the impact of the joint
programs or the two programs on water
and energy usage and then a fourth thing
will be able to look at is the impact of
water reports on energy usage and energy
reports on water usage so great question
the reason why I probably think it's so
good is we're looking at this question
ourselves
great and we have a number of questions
about being the customer base used in
the study so first are you segmenting
customers based on demographics age
family size etc to see the effect on
usage and how does the study incorporate
people who live in apartments or condos
that don't receive water bills
so again really good great great
questions so when we did our
randomization which we just finished up
we weren't able to stream stratify
customers on demographic characteristics
why was that well we don't have that
data so what we were able to do was we
randomized and then we tested to see if
households were balanced in their summer
water usage their winter water usage the
second thing we did is there was one
concern about kind of renter forces
owners and so we excluded apartments
from our study so it's only comprised of
single-family homes however to get at
the principal-agent problem it would
also be really interesting to see how
renters versus owners respond to these
types of policies great thank you our
next question is from Emma how did you
get the data for the water score
comparisons on the home water courts
where their barriers to getting more
granular data 15-minute data
um yeah so you know so I'm guessing a
lot of people might work with electric
utilities and so where we see a lot of
smart meters happening in the kind of
the energy sector it's the case that
there's fewer smart meters out there in
terms of water consumption so we were
just thrilled that we were able to get
hourly interval data right now Burbank
isn't equipped to collect data and 15
minute intervals I wish we were able to
get the data in in in 15 minute
intervals but we can in terms of the
social comparisons for similar neighbors
I believe what that's kind of what water
smart does so I can speculate as to an
answer but I can't say it with perfect
confidence so what it does water smart
they send out a survey and they collect
information about a household so what
the household characteristics look like
and what not and then they find
households that have kind of similar
demographic characteristics and they
then go on to compare a household usage
to the usage among similar neighbors
well we'll have since we kind of are
simple is comprised of 18,000
single-family homes we essentially kind
of have the population of single-family
homes in Burbank so we will be able to
draw from that when we're making our
comparisons
great the next question is from Patti
this these reports look similar to the
type of analysis and behavioral center
rising that au pair spearheaded in the
energy industry what are some challenges
that are different for water and where
have you been able to learn from similar
techniques in the electricity industry
wow that's a really really good question
so you know water smart it does it looks
really really similar to the 0 power
interventions you know I think of kind
of at least for me electricity and water
are somewhat different beasts in the
sense that you can think about
electricity what we're really concerned
about is not just overall energy
conservation but also more importantly
kind of load management when are these
reductions in usage happening are they
kind of occurring during the times when
it's most costly to supply electricity I
would say something that's also really
different about water and energy in
California deals also with kind of the
fragmentation of water utilities so in
California we have three main kind of
electric utilities but we have hundreds
of water utilities so Burbank is one you
can imagine glendale's another so all of
these cities in a way are their own
water utilities so kind of the
fragmentation of it makes it very
different also these puppies water
utilities and this isn't so much from
the home water report but it's trying to
think about how to manage water usage
water utilities tend to be publicly
owned so kind of you have to so managing
them is it kind of a whole different
process so you can think about with
electricity we tend to have great cases
but with water often kind of this kind
of go before the City Council and people
have to vote on it so as I'm learning
about kind of how water differs from
energy there's just a lot of differences
in in the sectors themselves i'm trying
to think as I kind of tick off kind of
the line items what else I guess another
thing that's really different between
water and electricity and this is
particularly so in California is we're a
huge drought right and we're trying to
figure out how to best conserve water
well in California the largest consumer
of water is agriculture so even if we
get kind of urban users to reduce the
water usage kind of in terms of the
overall water savings it's not going to
have that big effect just because
agriculture is the dominant user so i
guess i didn't provide that many
insights into the home water reports for
this home energy reports but hopeful
I was able to paint some one of the
picture about the distinctions between
the water and energy sectors great and
we have another question so how are the
water saving recommendations Keith
historical water used
you
so I think what WaterSmart tries to do
is they run these surveys for households
that are in their treatments and they
try to figure out kind of also what
durable goods they have so you can
imagine if a household responds by
saying that they have an efficient
clothes washer than in the
recommendation they're not going to
provide a recommendation or an action to
purchase an efficient clothes washer if
they already have a low-flow showerhead
like a high-end one and they report that
they have one you can imagine that water
smart isn't going to recommend in their
treatment that they go install a little
shower head another good example is if
we know that a household doesn't have a
pool which hopefully will collect in the
survey then water smart is again not
going to recommend that a household
decrease kind of the pool temperature by
2 degrees just because a household
doesn't have a pool great and I think
we'll dispute questions and I wrap up so
this one is from Roger with a collection
of hourly data on these homes was there
any thoughts of providing real-time
information back to individual customers
is real-time data is important in gas
and water as an electricity
um gosh really gosh everyone's asking
really good questions um and I wish I
had answers to them all I mean I guess I
can just give my two cents on them all
their things kind of Iraq my mind with
as well right so I'm sure I think the
question was comprised of two pieces the
first the second I'll go to the second
part first which is how should the
manager how does the management of water
in natural gas compared to electricity
yeah they're definitely different beasts
with electricity it's really critical
that we understand when consumers are
consuming electricity because the price
to provide electricity you know in terms
of a kind of from a wholesale
perspective differ so much kind of
within a day and across days for water
you know the same doesn't hold true but
I think it's really important if we want
to understand kind of when and how
people are using if we won't understand
when and how people are conserving water
I think it's really critical that we
have this high interval data that is
with this high interval data will be
able to tease out whether households are
responding by taking shorter showers or
whether they're responding by watering
their lawns less frequently will be able
to see and look at the margins of
response and what that will help us with
is will help us figure out how to best
target water conservation and the same
holds for natural gas conservation so I
think I answered your question Lynn let
me know if I've missed part of it
great and the last question is from
Michael when do you expect results from
the study
Michael well that's a great last
question so Michael we're hoping what
will so this it's supposed to be
launched in April so we've done the
randomization and we're just kind of
working out some of the kinks so
hopefully these results will start to
trickle in on by summer right and but I
think the really interesting data will
come at the end of the summer because
that's when there's a lot of water usage
in Southern California so hopefully kind
of if you check in with me by the summer
end of the summer will start to have
some preliminary results and maybe if
I'm really lucky and I'll plug myself um
the Center for business in the
environment will invite me back in a
year to provide an update on kind of the
results from our study so I just want to
thank everyone again for taking the time
to listen home to the webinar and also
for the really really good questions i
wish i had more definitive answers but a
lot of the questions you're asking are
the same questions that kind of we're
asking here at the center thanks so much
katrina that concludes our talk today on
water and energy synergies and we are
going to have water smart on our webinar
series in a few months and to also
provide an update and kind of dig into
some of the questions questions that
folks are asking but if you want would
like to view or share recording of
today's webinar please visit the
blueprint for efficiency website all of
our current and past webinars are under
the events tab and please make sure to
tune in next Thursday Marchmain six for
our webinar on harnessing energy
embedded in water this webinar will
feature a few key studies of joint
utility efficiency programs including
stories of firsthand experiences with
the process in addition we will
highlight some emergency technologies
that can be used to harness the energy
embedded and water including key studies
have net zero energy waste water
treatment plants this is linh tran from
the yale center for business in the
environment saying so long from New
Haven Connecticut